la parole est à Monsieur Pierre Charron
pour le groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur millise Affaire
étrangères
asiabi est une jeune chrétienne
pakistanaise condamnée à mort pour
blasphème contre le prophète
ce qu'elle a toujours nié
asiabibi paie le prix de ses convictions
qu'elle ne veut pas renier la vérité
nous oblige à reconnaître que le crime
d'asiabibi c'est tout simplement sa foi
chrétienne et rien d'autre son ka
illustre à lui seul les différentes
persécutions que subissent les chrétiens
dans certains pays où il ne fait pas bon
appartenir à une minorité religieuse
asiabibi est tout simplement un bouc
émissaire dans les sociétés guidées par
les démons du rejet et de l'intolérance
elle témoigne de ce calvaire permanent
ont duré par des millions de chrétiens
en Irak en Syrie au Pakistan ou sévit la
nouvelle barbarie du 21e siècle
l'affaire est si sensible au Pakistan
que certains n'osent plus défendre à
ziabibi un gouverneur de province et un
ministre ont même été assassiné parce
qu'ils avaient pris feter cause pour la
jeune chrétienne la justice pakistanaise
redoutant la vindique des foules et la
violence des fanatiques préfèrent faire
profil bas quitte à destinée les
principes fondamentaux du droit
emprisonnés depuis 2009 asiabibi a été
condamné à mort en novembre 2010 la
Haute cour de la Horde a confirmé le 16
octobre dernier cette condamnation à
mort un recours a été déposé devant la
course suprême le 24 novembre 2014
de nombreuses mobilisations ont eu lieu
aussi bien en France que dans le monde
entier des pétitions ont été signés des
élus sont montés au créneau la
diplomatie doit aussi montrer son
courage dans ces questions et ne pas se
retrancher derrière la prudence quand la
prudence est partout le courage n'est
nulle part la France doit faire
comprendre au Pakistan que l'exécution
d'asiabibi serait un affront à tout ce
que nous avons de plus cher et qui va
bien au-delà de nos intérêts matériels
n'ayons pas peur de demander au
président pakistanais d'intervenir comme
l'a demandé le président Bruno
Retailleau au président de la République
française
asiabibi doit échapper à la peine de
mort et retrouver sa liberté son honneur
de croyance de femmes de mère de famille
je vous demande monsieur ministre de
nous dire ce que la France envisage pour
mettre fin à cette situation unique et
honteuse
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Harlem Désir se fait tard
d'État chargé des affaires européennes
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Pierre Charron la situation
d'asiabibi pakistanaise de confessions
chrétienne condamné à mort pour
blasphème nous révolte depuis la
première condamnation d'asiabibi en 2010
la France a constamment rappelé que la
notion de délit de blasphème était
contraire au principe des droits de
l'homme la France a également rappelé
son opposition à la peine de mort en
tout lieu et en toute circonstance la
France est très attachée au respect des
libertés fondamentales au titre
desquelles la liberté de religion
liberté de conviction liberté
d'expression qui sont protégés par des
traités internationaux ceci garantissent
en particulier le droit d'exprimer ses
opinions et de manifester sa religion
ces libertés sont définies en
particulier par la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et le Pacte
international sur les droits civils et
politiques que le protestants à ratifier
en juin 2010 la France protège les
minorités religieuses et en particulier
les minorités chrétiennes qui sont
aujourd'hui menacées dans plusieurs pays
concernant la situation d'asiabibi de
nombreuses démarches ont été effectuées
depuis 4 ans à tous les niveaux en lien
avec nos partenaires européens mais
comme vous venez de le rappeler monsieur
le sénateur la Haute cour de la Horse
saisie en deuxième instance à confirmé
le 16 octobre dernier la condamnation à
mort d'aziabibi pour délits de blasphème
dès le lendemain du verdict la France a
fait part de sa profonde préoccupation
et appelait une nouvelle fois le
Pakistan à respecter ses engagements
internationaux le président de la
République est intervenu personnellement
auprès de son homologue pakistanais pour
plaider la cause d'Asie Habibi au niveau
européen la Haute représentante a
également exprimé sa grande inquiétude
et espérer un recours rapide auprès de
la Cour suprême asiabibi vient de faire
appel de ce verdict devant la Cour
suprême dans ce cadre le gouvernement
français fait et fera tout ce qui est en
son pouvoir
pour qu'un dénouement positif puisse
intervenir le plus tôt possible je vous
le redis avec net T et sans aucune
prudence la condamnation à mort d'Asie
Habibi pour blasphème et révoltante
inhumaine et inacceptable c'est la
position de la France nous appelons la
communauté internationale à se mobiliser
avec la France et l'Union européenne
pour faire annuler cette 100 ans et pour
faire annuler une condamnation fondée
sur le blasphème car nous ne l'acceptons
ni au Pakistan ni ailleurs dans le monde
et nous ferons tout pour sauver asiabibi
merci monsieur le ministre